好 斯多頭又來唱多了 這樣的
我們今天主要講幾個事情
因為上週兩週前
那個時候我們比較明確地說過的美聯儲政策
雖然這週三美聯儲要進行
這週三大革命還是要降息
這週三美聯儲降息
然後我覺得聯儲政策我們上兩週討論過
其實就是一個點
我覺得叫Train has left the station
大家這個政策已經比較明確了
就不管怎麼說 它都是會偏軟的
然後明年會想出一些辦法來那個放出流動性
這個無外乎是J-PAL在臺上還是Hazard
就是現在Kavin Hazard可能會做新的聯儲主席
那市場其實
沒有太多的反應
那個聯儲主席大家還在等
他最後會出什麼樣的公開講話啊
他都會怎麼樣
但是我覺得不管誰在那個臺上去做這個事情
它都是一個偏軟的態度
那麼我覺得這週我可能
上週講比較多的宏觀的東西
這週我覺得兩
幾個事情就第一個就是我們對
操作上對於美股或者對資本這個風險資產
那麼在什麼樣的時點可以買然後明年的展望是怎麼樣
然後
這是一個 第二呢就是我可能會說一下行業的東西
那我這邊沒有準備行業的PPT
但是我覺得行業主要講兩個事情吧
一個是NV典因為的
另外一個是Intel
我覺得這兩個公司就是我最近關注的比較多的
那我分享一下就是
近期以來大家還有可能還有Oracle
大家一直在集中在做空Oracle
然後再重新配置
很多人在重新配置資產
把那個AI上的資產配置到Healthcare
就是健康就是醫療
還有那個銀行行業上面去
那麼這個是華爾街很多人在幹事這樣
那麼這個東西的背後我的看法就是對於行業一個細則看法
然後第三呢我可能會說一下
日本
最近
get a lot of attention
就大家很關注它
那個不光是高市上臺以後對中國的這種政治態度
這個我覺得不是特別重要
那個比較重要的是日本在那個
財政政策和貨幣政策上會變得更加分裂
也就是它對於通脹的預期
因為大家現在開始pricing日本
可能90%的pricing嘛
12月18號下下週
下週四的時候日本會進行一次申息
日本又要申息
那就是
其實在一年多以前日本有過一段時間
inflation so up很高
然後大家對通脹的那個預期很高
然後這次好像又來了
然後而且是服務業老東業成本
是一起在變高
所以對日本的這個看法我覺得比較重要
因為這個國家過去十多年以來
可能更長時間吧
一直是全球流動性的側緣地
阿爾蘇能下的carry trade
都是從日本出來的
日本藉著那個利率
然後一系然後去美國去買美戰
給美國提供的東西
那麼
carry trade會怎麼樣
然後我覺得這個對於日本
日本是大家一個關注的焦點
主要這三方面
就是美聯儲在沒有數據情況下去降息
然後日本的情況
然後那個行業
然後我先說一下就是
我覺得先提一下日本吧
就是日本這個你可以看到
就是上週的時候日圓的
就
上週的時候日本的那些國債排滿
還是web receipt還是很不錯的
然後呢
現在一來看那個MOF
就財政部那邊
畜財會改變他的發債的規模
就是說
還是會繼續發挺多的債
然後十年和三十年
可能會變得更加Steady
也就意味著三十年的日本國債的利率可能會往上跑
整體日本國債的這個利率往上跑
趨勢還是比較明顯
你看到下面
然後背後呢
還有的日本的這個
加息的這個威脅
就我個人覺得日本的央行
從
一般來說
他們是偏割愛的
即使在
你可以看一年多以前
一年多以前日本搞過一次這個事情
就是
那個時候要去交YCC
然後要加息
然後通常上升
然後
這個但是呢
本質上日本又是一個
pn
就是它的骨子裡
是一個非常非常各派的政府
所以
它是很糾結的
就是它是一個非常分裂和糾結的
你可以看到那個高市的態度
它對於那個
它對於那個economy的經濟態度是
就是說
它要做那個
expanation就是那個
財政要擴張
然後又reflationary
現在已經有inflation
還有reflationary
但是短期裡面通常預計太高
那個bio接要去降息
所以最後呢我其實覺得日本是會
就是
有點像
你媽打你的感覺就是你確實是通常上去了
確實做了壞事
但是呢它打你的確實下不了橫手
這個就是bio接一直以來的那個
骨子裡的態度
因為日本通縮的實際上
因為日本通縮的時間實在太長了
所以任何在
通縮可能會發生威脅的時候
日本採取的態度它會更加堅決它不是完全不平衡
你可以說美國現在也是不平衡的
也就是說美國對於就業的反應
它會比對通脹的反應要更大
那如果你把美聯儲的態度乘上了幾倍那就是bio接的態度
bio接它會
鷹派嘛就比較
升一次息我覺得12月18號大革慮還是會升息
然後升了息以後
日元的利率曲線會有反應嗎?會的
然後也會對carry trade造成影響
這個都是在短期裡會造成影響
但是在medium上面
在一個更加中期的一個時間裡面
那個
高市的
首相的這個高市政府的態度是要
財政擴張
要refrationary
然後同時的話它bio接並不是那麼獨立的
所以bio接會受到很大的壓力去把利息放很高
而且bio接本身的態度也不會
也不會把利息放很高
所以現在我是覺得
比方說明年在macro市場上
因為現在大家開始pricing90%
它要升息
而且inflation swap也挺高的
所以
我是覺得明年一個比較convicted macro trade是日元要貶值
就是你在日元貶值的這個週期裡面
carry trade又會有特別大的問題
雖然你看到這個利率在上升
然後可能它會升一次息
讓它短期的機率上升
讓carry trade的空間變小
但是
日本的政策
就是高市的政策和bio接本身的態度決定了日本的
就是它的強硬是
怎麼說呢
叫做
就是
看上去很強硬
但其實不會那麼強硬
所以這個是我對日本的一個本質的看法
就是明年日元還是會走弱
weekly end是一個大的趨勢
那麼weekly end的後面的結果是什麼呢
就是high equity
就是股票要漲
不管是美國和全球都會提供的東西
就是對於risky asset相對於來說
對於那個風險資產來說
我覺得是偏看好的
那麼當然在日本
它的那個高市的態度有很多了
它要在各種行業上面做扶持
它要在defence
就是國防
AI
nuclear
shared beauty
這些東西都會
但是雖然 despite
不管是日本利率會走高一點
但是整體的話
它的財政主義還是比較明確的
那麼
美國在沒有數據的情況下要去
要去降息
其實上周五唯一出來一個pce
pce偏好一點
就是它沒有那麼高
是吧
但是你現在連處我們可預見的
就是明天是大概率是要降息的
但是降息完以後
主要的關注並不是它降了不降
降了以後是看有多少
我們叫多少
就是聯儲內部有多麼的分裂
聯儲內部就是分裂的情況
決定了明年比方說
canva asset的上去
沒看它 asset大概率會被trump提名
就trump肯定會提名自己的一個
比較中心
或者是比較聽自己話的人
這個是大概率的
但是不管提名聽話還是不聽話
聯儲最終是要
聯儲最終還是要遵從這個經濟基本的事實的
也就是說我是覺得明年加兩次
就已經是相比很多投降的看法來說
已經是比較
我覺得我已經是比較各派的
但是更大的流動性會來自於
我上上周講的就是各種各樣的擴表
就不管是銀行鬆綁也好
擴表也好
這種東西
因為你本質深吸的
你雖然說那個pce看上去好一點
但是現在還是在2.8
那明年
明年tariff的影響是會變小的
就是那個2.8
他可能會往2.5左右或2.2走
但是在明年中期的時候
你畢竟不能變成副理系
所以聯儲降息的整體的空間沒有那麼大
就這是我個人看法
就是那個Kamahasa上去以後
其實還是會偏各派
那麼為什麼市場特別關注他的分裂呢
因為不管誰當聯儲主席
他都是偏各派的
但是聯儲能夠往前動多少
取決於內部的矛盾有多大
現在明確的有兩票
是已經是反對了上次
反對上
又鷹派的在反對
所以各派的希望降50個點
但是鷹派的是希望不要講息
甚至有更加激進
那麼這個分裂是會讓聯儲就是
就像美國現在政壇一樣
就左派右派很分裂
聯儲也一樣
各派和鷹派也很分裂
所以他們這個分裂的情況
會取決於聯儲往前走
走多少
怎麼走
那麼主席不用擔心
主席肯定是屁股往左邊走
就是往各派那邊走
所以另外就是我上幾週一直說的
美國國債
其實從國債的利率
你從日本也是
日本國債利率和卡住的
好了
OK
就是從日本的國債利率和Macro上
從利率能夠看到很多東西
這是過去一週
這個10年期利率的走勢
就是美國10年期利率
我我一直是覺得
10年期這個東西
就是應該在4.2左右
在年底
就是它的發債量畢竟放在哪裡
10年期打到4%
靠的是美國政府官們
那是1月份
他在鬧鬧一次
我不知道
但是靠美國政府官們沒有供應量
然後市場不確定性
風避險
然後一起把它打到4%
到了4%
其實就是一個送錢的角度
就是那個對於Macro市場來說
送錢
它是很難維持住的
所以美國現在到4.2
那明年其實我們說
經濟的基本面是靠著
美國的經濟基本面
其實是靠著Tariff的影響變少
關稅的影響變少
Physical就財政擴張的影響變大
然後這兩個影響
NAT在這個是在QE
這是高市女性的QE
可能在QE-QR之間
就是它的總影響會變正
就是它的
我放這個Tariff影響
沒有像財政擴張的影響這麼大
所以在26年整體會變正
所以你會看到26年一季度二季度變正
一季度二季度財政變正
它的影響
它對經濟的影響
可能在二季度三季度四季度出來
所以其實明年的經濟基本面
我們回頭來看是偏看好的
除非財政方面遭鬧出一些非常極端的事情
我覺得基本面還是看好的
所以你這種情況下
我就說一下我最後想說的Tariff
就是行業的Tariff
這個我沒有準備PVD
另外補充一個
就是你們會看到就短期
非常短期的話
你們會看到我上周下降很快
就是波動率下降很快
這個波動率下降快是過去
沒有多少次這麼快的快速下降
所以我看到推特上或者是小紅書上
有很多說美國AR泡沫的人
然後說美國要崩潰的人
那個基本上他們是不看頭寸的
不看倉位
這個和去年我就警國跟去年完全不一樣
因為你可以把所有錢放在外面的錢
都認為是多頭
那麼在過去一個月
November 11月份的時候
CTA本身就屏藏了700多億
但是CTA屏藏700多億
和CTA加波控制
就是這兩個叫波動率控制
一個叫CTA就是70分鐘
還有一種就是根據波動率來說
波動率越大
那我就超越小
波動率越小
我就超越大
那麼這樣的倉位
這兩個統稱 were systematic position
就是那個系統性倉位
那這種系統性倉位減少了
就CTA裡面就減少了70多億
70個別人700多億
那他們其實都是潛在多頭
因為他們是無腦料會進去的
那上週我們看到VO下降了這麼快
那這些錢都要回到市場上去了
CTA和Vocantr
都是根據VO要調整它的倉位百分比
那這些倉位回去即使在flag case
就是我們認為股票不漲不跌的情況下
它一天要進去七個別臉
就是70億
這個不小的
就是從週一開始到下週五
就這週一開始到週五
所以你從短期的倉位來講
它也是比較supportive
然後從更中長期的經濟基本命來說
也是更比較supportive
所以你如果說在希望預期
就是降息升息預期達成週三以後
然後市場開始下跌
那有可能就覺得這個概率還是挺大的
但是這個下跌的幅度絕對不會預期到
像去年今年4月份
最多是像去年本來說89月份這種市面
我覺得都不一定有
因為現在多頭太多了
其實就是暢空的人全是多頭
你可以看所有推特上面的一些暢空
看k線看美股
然後說因為我們現在位置太高
然後要往下調
那個比方說
我們華爾街現在幫做空allocle
覺得AI是泡沫的人
他們他們
其實你能夠確定的知道
他們明年全部要被打臉的
然後這個這個宏觀面我講過很多次
然後確定他們明年都會被打臉
然後在短期裡面
其實也沒有特別多的資金去支持
就是倉位你們打出來倉位去支持
所以你們不會看到一個特別深的回調
就是有回調就是機會
然後行業裡面我說一個這個事情
就是上次我其實提到過
就是很多人整個macrohyperscale
大家都有可能會去買英文大的芯片
然後tpu這個東西呢
芯片這個事情其實是三方面的
就是一方面是你要看performance
pouart就是它的表現
它沒完的表現需要用的電力的表現
另外一個是靈活度
第三個其實你要看它成本
tpu確實成本很低
但是你不可能說我現在表現說
因為你簡單的想那個雲廠的業務
就跟簡單的工廠其實是一樣的
我有需求
我有產出
我有一個地
然後我有電輸進去
然後我有功能把它加工了
就變成產品是不是
其實是一模一樣的商業模式
它只是用的是芯片不是功能而已
那你不能說我現在造一個廠
然後如果說極端缺貨的情況下
我其實是造越自動化的廠
然後它的輸出效率越高越好
對吧
它不是說我要造很多手工的
勞動的這個成本低的工廠
那麼tpu它本質
就是tpu證明了谷歌證明了
scaling老師有效的
就是我只要堆疊更多的算力
我有更好的模型
所以整個市場的需求會越來越大
那麼在這個變得更大的過程中
其實大家應該追求的是performance
PW也就是我同樣耗電下面
我的功率能到多少
而且就領還有靈活度
就是那邊臉還是有靈活度
所以這個點來衡量
沒有一個芯片能比得過那邊臉
就是tpu它能夠解決谷歌內部的一些問題
但是tpu這個東西
就是你要說asic和tpu去取代尼韻偉達
這個事情是侯尼瑪約很久
我覺得甚至不太可能
就是在模型疊帶的時候
還需要一些的靈活度的情況下
我覺得這個可能性基本上你可以認為它很難
那麼而且第二就是谷歌為什麼有這麼多的gpu
然後有那麼大的算力
因為谷歌是台積電的大客戶
最大的客戶
台積電本身你可以認為所有的手機的芯片
手機要么就是安卓
要么就是蘋果的
所以安卓的包括media take
包括Pocon
包括其實三星
三星很多片的也都是台積電留的
那最後
最後那個它最大客戶是谷歌
谷歌的運說我有很多的流片的現成
中間我拿了一些現成
幫我tpu拿到了現成
最終能夠誰能夠掌握算力
就是cobos現成分給誰誰就有算力
你就是在張東某掛掉之前
就沒有人能夠撼動
就是你可以這樣想
就是現在大家在逼那筆點
去放棄自己的像
像cobels
像lambda這些小弟
然後能夠把片直接給到hyperscale
給那些大廠
所以那些大廠
就是說我先去買tpu
你不給我就買tpu是beta
就是我需要拿到更多的
那個英偉達的配貨
那同樣
英偉達在扶植lambda和扶植
那個扶植cobels
那同時的話
台積電在扶植誰
他現在扶植英偉達
所以英偉達背後的共和
和他的cobels的現成
是由張東某去鎖定
所以只要台積電裡面有很多證證
但是只要張東某沒有掛掉
那個英偉達是不會有豐獲的問題
那最終的瓶頸在哪裡
在TSMC在那個台積電
就是
所以我覺得就從業務上來說
其實一個從技術上來說
第二個從豐獲上來說
都根本就不用擔心英偉達的業績的問題
所以英偉達業績明年會到什麼
我覺得會到9.5
美股
那就是他恢復到7次的增速
這個是一個很恐怖的
因為現在scaling law更有效
scaling law有效的情況下
我們明去年擔心的是英偉達的增速不夠
但是今年增速還要加速
就今年60 明年70
它的麻景還在增加
所以在這樣一個狀況下
那個
現在英偉達180塊錢
180多昨天晚上稍微漲了一點
那個這個數字是完全不算中國的
就中國那個H200
就今天早上川普時候會給中國賣的H200
這個數據還沒有算上去
就是英偉達大概18倍
18倍到19倍p
在滿月運漲明年的數據還算上
所以這個位置上去做工
也就是你會看到整個
整個SMP的指數裡面
幾些大頭的公司
包括像你的vdn
它的估值很低的
它並不是在高位
你不能看價格的
你這東西要看它的這個而已
然後補吃一個最近有很多人說的
說英偉達咱們左腳踩右腳
就AR的東西左腳踩右腳
我上次也說過這個數據
就是你每
你每一個月活客戶的維護的成本
每一個月活客戶維護的成本
在OpenAR 11.5
你在抖音的初期你可以看看
你在小紅書的初期
包括你在所有的互聯網
就中國互聯網大戰
這些平臺互相燒錢
比方說甚至旅遊的平臺阿里
這個那個協成去跟什麼
協成去跟那個那家去打
他們其實都是在燒錢
這個燒錢越活的維護成本都很高
都遠遠比OpenAR高
OpenAR人家還模型
所以你說
如果你把OpenAR分開來說
它會不會倒掉呢
它不會倒掉
它下的單就沒有問題
它下的單就是它
哪怕它沒錢
它肯定會被其他人買掉
就被蘋果啊
會被NVIDIA
因為大家這些賣掉
他們直接能實施販備的
那它這種標的
它直到不會倒
它往前面的就是相當於
它是最大的客戶
它是訂單的客戶
不然不光是OpenAR
還Android
那麼它的訂單就是有效的
它訂單有效的
那麼所有華爾街去做空
Orco的邏輯就不存在
Orco是所有去做空AI的前線表
因為它槓桿率比較高
Orco是說
我能夠有這麼多的訂單
我要去Fill這些訂單
所以呢
我要去槓桿
我要去遭運運算計中心
這邏輯很簡單
我現在手上拿了訂單
然後我要去遭到廠給它
給它造出來
你就給它給它出貨
那人家說
你這個訂單到時候人家不付錢了
你的客戶不靠譜
你客戶OpenAR到時候破產了
OpenAR維護一個客戶
一個月才一塊五
它怎麼會破產呢
它維護成名比抖音還便宜
所以這個就是背後的反了一個邏輯
所以我先說的是英偉達
就是英偉達這個明年確定性
就業績上來說
其實是確定性最高的
而且新半導體這個東西
它並不是移動互聯網
移動互聯網
你一旦看到有個新的東西出來以後
你會覺得
它很快會取代原來的模式
比方說你現在看到半導體裡面
你覺得Azik出來
我們是不是Azik會取代
包括TPU在內
這是類Azik的東西
是不是定制滑芯片會取代
英偉達
那不可能的
半導體是很長很長時間的
就好像英特爾出的問題
它是沒有接下蘋果的訂單
那出了好多年之後才影響到它
英特爾今天英特爾
好像大家一開始做多臺
英特爾到我講
英特爾大家又開始做多臺
那英特爾做多臺
它的原因是那個成立武馬
它根本不跟利普臺
沒有利普臺
沒有任何的關係
它是那個PAT
在過去三年搞了五條現產
四年搞了五條現產
那個把那個英特爾放置給搞出來了
所以這個背後的東西
都是需要很長時間去incrubate
所以當你看到TPU好像很好
那麼你們可能不知道的是
Google在大規模下帶去賣NVD的新片
雖然Google去賣了
比方說Anthopia去53個別臉
Over五年時間去買TPU
但是它這是Over五年時間
到時候能不能deliver都不好說
能不能有現成
能deliver多了都不好說
但是谷歌自己當季
現在在拼命的買英偉達的片
而且要鎖定英偉達的片
那英偉達明年的這個營利
我覺得情況是其實是
我覺得不用特別擔心
就根本不用特別擔心
然後當然你可以看谷歌這公司
其實這樣子Deep Mind在
就是它的AI的部門
在買英偉達的片
但是它的語音的部門
確實是在賣TPU
那其實公司業我要風扇一下
你說它為什麼TPU自己還不夠了
還要我完賣
那我試一試外面人
可不可以用我的生態
但是主要的TPU供給誰呢
肯定還是要供給Deep Mind
還是要供給自己內部的AI
所以你會看到
不是說東東亞島西方
而是說現在整個半導體行業
面臨的明年的需求缺口非常大
這個明年的需求是
就好像我去遭到一個高速公路
然後遭到高速公路市場
大家說遭高速公路以後
明年有沒有車開
現在車團堵住了
沒有路了
但是你這個高速公路
通車以後明年有沒有
那明年肯定是負荷全滿
負荷全滿的情況下
大家就會考慮今年
因為它這個東西
今年用的基建是去年了
然後今年的基建是給明年用
那明年全滿的情況下
大家討論後年會不會全滿
這個不知道
但是至少明年肯定會全滿
明年全滿
就是你會發現
在明年的投資方面
就是後年的供貨上
那個明年投資上面
所有東西都會缺貨
我們談到缺貨的問題
就是今年你看到Sora出來以後
那個存儲的缺貨
但是存儲缺貨跟Sora沒有關係
模型更早的就出來了
那個存儲一直在缺貨
只是sora出來吵了一把
那我現在告訴大家的是
那個我們現在看到CSP
對於CPU的下單
那個是非常恐怖的
就是各家
那個為什麼本質上
會對CPU代理線打過我們的下單
因為Agent多了
就原來我調用一個Agent
是我等於是我
做做做吹牛
或者是我的那個GPT本身在調用
那調用的時候
那個CPU和GPU的
本身它的上理中心
GPU為主
CPU為副
CPU很少
那麼不需要那麼多的CPU
但是當你的Agent使用的場景
更多的時候
那Agent去調用這個
GPU的時候
它是程序化去調用的
它是一直在那裡刷刷刷刷刷
所以這種情況下
一旦有更多的Agent
就是使用場景
實際使用場景越多
CPU就會需要越大
現在CPU缺貨非常嚴重
明年大概20到30
27年搞不好30
明年至少20
所以有大量的這個CPU的缺貨
而且是常規負載不夠
那還有這個原因
所以CPU整體缺貨
那麼在CPU缺貨情況下
你有兩家可以選
你一家去選AMD
AMD也會很好
因為AMD也缺貨
就是反正缺貨就是
明年半導體行業
音缺進缺
只要有東西全部缺貨
所以在AMD上面
AMD的這個CPU是追求PW的
那PW肯定是很對的一個方案
就是說我們剛剛講到
你怎樣是吧
你在甩理中心你在GPU上
你英偉達的好處就是它PW
因為我有線的這個工廠的情況下
我要產出更高
但是當我缺貨的時候
我不是這樣考慮的
我是考慮Performance最高
因為我不考慮它有多少點
你本身就缺貨
電不是constraint
constraint是有多少塊片
現在可能唯一在供貨上
有一些彈性的就是intel
intel在供貨上可能會有一些彈性
AMD是沒有彈性的
因為AMD靠的是TSMC的流片
TSMC現在不單止Wafer Subject全部求貨了
就是很難擴張了
intel是用intel3和intel4在流片
所以intel3和intel4
它會把一部分Modern比較低的
consumer的片
然後去不流
然後去放到服務器的新片上面去流片
所以我正好發過一個推特講這個事情
就是現在我們看到資金上面
去追捧intel的資金
恰恰是臺灣的資金
就是那幫半導體的資金
現在在暢空intel
因為intelModern比較低
那個說它Modern低
然後說它Fundry和它的產品
兩個一起算Modern
一起算Modern
你把它算到29塊錢
算到20幾塊錢
那些都說華爾街的
像UBS那些人
他們是怎麼算的
但是半導體的行業不是怎麼算
半導體行業是算
我的Fundry只要我的這個流經元廠
我的經元廠只要正常工作的經元廠
那它就應該
Globo這麼老的經元廠是1.7倍
然後TSMC的PB
就PBL
其實是TSMC的PB
好像是七倍吧
七倍八倍
七八倍的樣子
然後intel的PB是0
現在還是0
因為它的CPU這塊業務
明年在缺貨的情況下
至少就是2000億
但是它投了1000億的經元廠
現在PB還是0
之前是負的
因為我覺得它破產
現在被那個政府救了以後
就是在英偉達和美國政府進去的時候
給它估值估在0
但是這個價格是一個
我覺得至少對intel來說
是一個非常過分的價格
就是大家很多人會看
就是這個半導體的周期是很長
所以我當我最早講intel的時候
2025年年初的時候
我就說2025年三季度是會比較難的
然後三季度過了以後
後面就是慢慢變好
因為半導體是需要時間的
18A的設計
PDK的設計不是給外部用的本來
所以後面做了一個
18AP是給外面用的
所以它的現成是沒有問題的
但是PDK不是很好
但是PDK後面要更新
但是14A的PDK
設計就是給外部使用的
現在大家已經開始
因為去年還在說intel
流平很差
良率很差
但是intel的良率的提升
是每個月完之二到五
這個速度跟它今天差不多
也就是18A它的進度
就是它的那個現成
對標是N3
N3或者N2
對標N3
它對標N3現在的良率
確實沒有它幾點高
人家在70
就是intel在70
但是你想我留自己的片
我留自己的片70
和給台積電90
不是一回事嗎
你的那個良率的差
本身也就變成台積電
毛利被台積電給轉走了
所以你要自己留片
你能夠有60 70就夠用了
就是我如果60
就跟交給台積電的流片成本是一樣
明白我意思
因為台積電還要賺錢
那麼你給外部客戶用
你確實要到90
但是它現在18A的良率的提升速度
就是美國也保持非常穩定
這個事情其實二二五年的時候
我們都知道
二二四年的時候
都看到intel的所有的晶圓廠的這個速度
都是差不多這個樣子
就是你要說它大規模的起亮
美國有各種各樣問題
OK是有的
但是人家晶圓廠
這個是有數據的
就是它的這個良率提高
確實是有數據的
那是14A流片
現在蘋果跟它談的第二是
本來是蘋果要給它研發費用
現在蘋果每年給那個
它可能到了27年的時候
這個是它的那個周期表
那個到了27年的時候
可能是6A19這樣子
然後可能那個時候最新愛20
然後6A19
所以14A對標是1.6
1.6台積電1.6的現成
所以14A本身是說蘋果要給intel這個費用
就是給它研發費用
現在可能是蘋果直接給它做投資
所以蘋果投intel的Deal
也是談了幾幾把吧
就是我們從行業內的信息知道
也是基本上是敲定
走投資的方案
然後比較快的會給錢的
所以在這個情況下面
就是說你可以看明年半導體就是缺貨
Azik市域
就是往遠看
非常就是比方說阿巴狗這些
有很大前景的東西
我們慢慢會take off那個
英偉達的這個market
但是明年快炒的就是投資比較快的
就是缺貨誰缺貨
因缺進缺
誰缺貨幫荒謬壞缺貨
誰缺貨你就去買哪個
那個現在CPU很確定的缺貨
CPU缺貨
而且先被搶光的就是intel
因為缺貨情況下肯定是買
不方便是比較好的
而且它有14A後面要去幫蘋果要去留片
因為我覺得陳立伍的就是
Lipton他的那個
對於華爾街的management
還是相對來說
在那個所有芯片公司裡面都是最好的
因為華人不太會manage這些東西
包括ALY的那個林伯
這些他都不太會掛
但是他本身是投資出城的
陳立伍是投資主持人intel CEO
他的投資主持人
所以他對於比方說
他上一次的業績
對於後面的麻捲
和對於後面的毛利隊
和對面後面的這個盈利
其實預期給了很低
市場還是比較埋障
就是其實對於intel來說
他已經到了一個要壞turning point的時候
這就是我對intel的尼泊唐
然後那個包括他18A
18Ap和18A的現成
然後我本質上
我覺得這個兩率都不是一個問題
給他一個簡單的估值
就是CPA2000元
Foundry如果兩倍PB的話
就是2000加一級4000元
所以他其他東西全部取貨
全部歸零
那是94000元
所以現在其實在半導體intel上
Oracle上
然後和英偉大商
大家都是在博弈
就是行業內的看法
行業內的資金
包括臺灣那幫資金
和美國對沖基金
就是美國的對沖基金
和華爾街那幫人的看法
或者是有很多散戶
看線的散戶
他們形成鮮明的不同的立場
所以我分享一下
因為華爾街的看法是這樣的
華爾街的看法很簡單
我的Oracle你的槓桿太高
你後面OpenAI能不能給錢
不知道你槓桿太高
所以大家後面的
整體的買貨的槓桿
都好
買貨的人的槓桿都很好
所以你相當於是自買自銷
那你一旦OpenAI一倒
你前面全部垮掉
這個是華爾街的看法
首先我覺得這個不大成立
我比較贊同半導體行業的看法
好吧
我今天講了比較多的
關於行業的一些信息
我看到他們在問CPO的那個東西
我待會群裡面回答大家
好吧
然後我今天會議就先到這裡了
謝謝大家的時間
我這個會議時間要到了